each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available so it's a pleasure to have
Mariana rova speaking today uh Mariana
is a research scientist at SRI she
graduated from Colombia and she did a
post at um IBM research um I guess most
of you know her she's done uh two no
three internships here two in the crypto
group and one in the security group um
and today she'll be speaking about
officiation thanks any uh hello everyone
uh today I'm going to present to you our
work on uh IND distinguishability of
fation and constructing uh functional
encryptions for all circuits uh this is
work uh in collaboration with sanjam gar
Craig Gentry Shai halevi mahai and the
brand
Waters so uh let me start by uh saying a
few uh nonformal words about uh what
obfuscation is so code obfuscation the
goal of code obfuscation is to uh make
programs unintelligible while at the
same time maintaining their
functionality so this is one example
that I took from Wikipedia of how uh
people uh currently do obfuscation and
what obfuscated programs look like so if
we uh say this initial goal there are
like several questions that arise
immediately uh first one obviously is
why why would we want to do anything
like this what good is this for the next
one is uh what unintelligible really
means is there a way to formalize what
this unintelligible means and then the
third one is uh once we have settled
these two question is can we really
achieve anything with these
properties so in this talk I hope that I
will give answers to all three of these
questions more or less satisfi you will
see uh so let's start with the first
question why would we want to do
obfuscation well obfuscation in general
gives us the ability to hide secrets in
software that's like at a very high
level so imagine that we have the uh as
which is a symmetric uh key encryption
uh and then we look at the circuit of
AES and we also embed there the secret
key that we will use for the encryption
so we start with the secret key
encryption and if we upate this circuit
we immediately get a public key
encryption so the obfuscation of this
AES circuit with the embedded key is a
public ke encryption and the advantage
is that if the obfuscation uh doesn't
add too much overhead then uh we have
more efficient public key encryption
scheme because in general symmetric key
is much more efficient than public key
so so another example that we can come
up with is imagine that we have a
company and we came up with some a
proprietary algorithm for DNA
classification and we would like to
release software that allows people to
use this algorithm but at the same time
we don't want to reveal our uh secrets
in designing this algorithm so what we
can do is we can provide an obfuscation
for our program that is implementing the
algorithm while hiding uh uh our
proprietor
information and then the third example
that I would mention is maybe when we
think about distribution of software
patches so assume that we have found out
that our program has some vulnerability
and we want to distribute a software
patch but if people are able to look at
this patch that we're Distributing this
would also immediately Point them to the
vulnerability so they can try and
leverage this into attacks of already
existing software however if we had a
way to upus skate this patch then we can
uh release this uh uh fix while not
while hiding the vulnerability as well
so these are in that example that you're
patching is it off or just the patch uh
I I mean once you want to apply the uh
patch then you have to no so actually
you don't need to have it upos skated
can be the clear
yeah so but uh and in in yep if it's in
the clear if you have an up fiscated
patch and the thing you're patching is
in the clear then you can see which part
is updated so you know where the
pability is yeah so I mean if you if you
assume that you can compare the two
things and then find out just by the
comparison on the whole code where the
the changes then then yeah so the
question is whether you maybe the patch
is much smaller and just by looking in
the patch you can get a direct uh
pointer to the place where you're
patching so in general uh
ofation is used in uh contemporary work
where people try to come up with ad hoc
uh solution for obfuscation which mostly
uh implement the the principle of
security VI obscurity so uh what they
really do is uh make time consuming re
reverse engineering uh on a particular
opos skated uh uh program but in no way
do they provide any provable uh
properties for these existing
obfuscations so this means that our
challenge as cryptographers is really to
construct ofation uh schemes that
provide uh provable security
guarantees and if you happen not to be
into application and you don't care
about applications of obfuscation I will
give you another motivation that you
might care about it is uh just by virtue
of the fact that obfuscation is a very
useful primitive and there is this whole
series of uh new uh results in crypto
that came out uh immediately after this
paper and that they Implement many new
and interesting functionalities which
were not possible uh before we had
obfuscation and for the purposes of this
talk I would actually uh focus on
functional encryption which is a result
from our paper so using alation we
construct the functional encryptions for
all circuits and here I'll take a little
uh deviation to tell you what this
functional encryption what kind of
functionality functional encryption
provides for you so basically functional
encryption uh is a generalization of uh
uh usual encryption schemes that give
you a way to uh Define a special type of
decryptions key decryption keys that
reveal uh not the whole encrypted
message but only a function evaluated on
this message so imagine that we have
Mary who has her a driving license and
then we encrypt the driving license
using functional encryption then when
Mary goes to the bar we can provide the
bar Ender with a key that allows him to
decrypt the cipher text for the from the
functional encryption and the only thing
that he learns is whether Mar is over
21 in the same thing we can provide a
policeman with a decryption key that
allows him just to learn the type of uh
driving category for Merry uh driving
license so this is the functionality of
functional encryption and I will later
show you how to construct
it so what are our results in this paper
that I will present from now on
so we proposed the first uh uh
indistinguishability of fation scheme
for all circuits there are two steps in
our constructions we first give a
candidate obfuscation constructions for
a shallow circuits or circuits that can
be instantiated in nc1 and then we show
how to use the ofation of nc1 circuits
together with fully homomorphic
encryption to obtain obfuscation for any
circuit in
P so this is our result on op fation and
then using opusc together with
functional encryption uh I will show you
how to construct a functional encryption
uh
scheme for the purposes of the
presentation I will uh shift a little
bit the order in which I will talk about
the different parts of our results and
the reason for this is that this is
really the most
uh complicated part the most messy part
maybe uh from the talk because this is
where uh we also introduce a new uh
hardness assumption so I will start from
the ones that are clean and uh smooth
constructions with with nice uh proofs
and then I will proceed to the more uh
complicated
one
yeah two applications of like Anonymous
credential examples as well well for
this particular example of functional
encryption yeah you can think of uh the
main distinguishing part is that you
could do those without interacting with
the person
uh I mean yeah you can just provide the
the cipher text and you you can do the
decryption on the cipher text you don't
need any any interaction beyond
that so let's let's now start with a
more formal definition of what opusc is
so an opusc is a probabilistic algorithm
that takes as input a certain program C
or a circuit C and then it outputs
another program which we will call the
opos
of this program C Prime and we want we
require the following three properties
from uh our
ofation first we want to guarantee that
the ofation of the function computes
exactly the the functionality that we
started with so on any input evaluation
of the original circuit is the same as
the evaluation of the obfuscated
circuit then uh we want to guarantee
that the ausc uh version of our program
introduces only polinomial overhead in
the original size of the starting
circuit and then the third property is
the property that I will still State
here as unintelligible because there are
many ways in which we can formalize the
unintelligible and I will uh explain uh
the several different flavors that uh we
can uh require for uh security yeah you
say poom larger what's the degree of the
polom have currently it's a large I I I
don't know the the exact degree but it's
very
large so the first way that we can
formalize the uh security for
obfuscation is what is called virtual
blackbox obfuscation and this uh
security definition tries to capture the
intuition that given an obfuscation for
a a circuit this does not reveal
anything more than a blackbox access to
the Circuit so it just allows us to feed
it inputs and see the outputs of the uh
computation but we don't learn anything
more uh apart from that and the formal
way that we State uh this uh security
definition is by saying that for every
polinomial time adversary a there exists
a simulator s such that for all circuits
The View uh that an adversary gets from
an the obfuscation of the circuits is
indistinguishable from A View that's
produced by the simulator which is given
only blackbox access to the
functionality so basically this captures
the fact that if there is a simulator
that can produce this in distinguishable
View and he's given just the blackbox
access to the Circuit then certainly the
obfuscation doesn't reveal anything
more so this is very strong uh and very
good uh security definition the B the
bad thing is that uh uh it's possible
and the work of Barako which also
introduced this definition uh shows that
uh achieving blackbox obfuscation is
impossible and in particular uh they
construct unusable families F together
with some property about these families
such that uh uh you can efficiently
compute uh this property if you given uh
any circuit that computes F however if
you're just given uh random Oracle
access to the functionality F there is
no way that you can uh compute this
property uh uh
p and also the impossibility result for
the virtual blackbox ofation uh extends
to the case when we allow inefficient op
foscor so the opusc algorithm doesn't
need to be polinomial time and still the
impossibility result
holds so uh if we have this
impossibility result the natural thing
is to try to look at a relaxed
definition of uh security for
obfuscation and here comes the notion of
indistinguishability obfuscation which
was also introduced in the same uh work
of Barack at all IND distinguishability
of fation uh tells us the following
it tells us that if we start uh with two
circuits that compute the same function
or this means that the evaluation on any
input of the circuit c0 is equal to the
evaluation of the uh on the same input
of the circuit C1 then uh the
obfuscations of the two circuits are
indistinguishable so note that uh
inefficient IND distinguishability of
vcation is always possible for this we
can think just about the lexic graphical
order of all circuits that Implement a
particular functionality and we can just
designate the first circuit in this
lexical graphical order as the
obfuscation for for this
functionality the only problem is that
uh Computing this canonical order is
inefficient so you you don't get
indistinguishability efficient we don't
know so far how to do IND efficient IND
distinguish ability
ofation
uh also uh uh goldwaser and R Blum
introduced the notion of best possible
obfuscation which tries to capture the
fact that uh the obfuscation of a
particular function doesn't uh allow a
learner to learn anything more than any
other uh uh circuit that implements the
same functionality if we're concerned
with just computational
indistinguishability
then the notion of best possible fation
is exactly the same as in
distinguishability of fation and since
we'll be really we'll be talking only
about computational indistinguishability
in this talk uh for us
indistinguishability ofation is
equivalent to best possible
fation so uh let's start with our actual
uh construction for in
distinguishability uh
ofation uh as I mentioned uh we it will
consti consists of two steps the first
step will be constructing in
distinguishability of skater for shallow
circuit and uh this construction would
be using multi-linear maps and then it
will be introducing some complex uh uh
new assumptions and that's why we will
leave it for for later and the Second
Step uh in our construction will be to
bootstrap the indistinguishability of
fation uh for nc1 together with the fom
morphic in encrypt
and to obtain in distinguishability of
fation for any Circuit of in
p uh this will be a simple and provable
construction and that's why uh we will
start with this construction so uh how
do we start with anation in nc1 and
obtain ofation for any
circuit well let's think about what uh
what are the properties that homomorphic
encryption gives us so we have some
function uh F that we want to compute an
opulation of this function so if we
imagine that we encrypt the function f
with FAL morphic encryption then we get
an encryption of this function and we
have the property that we can take any
plain text input and we can evaluate it
with this encrypted function and we will
obtain uh the final output f of x but
the only problem is that it's still it
will be encrypted under uh
FH so and in the uh in the function of
ofation we really want to be able to get
this uh output result in the
clear so also when we do this uh
evaluation we will keep a transcript of
all the steps that we uh performed when
we were evaluating the uh encrypted
function f on the plain text uh X so
now we can
imagine defining a circuit that takes
his input the plain text
x uh the result of the evaluation F ofx
and also this transcript that is telling
us exactly what happened in the
evaluation and we can
uh take this as a proof that we really
perform the evaluation of this encrypted
function f on the input X and we can
check that really the
evaluation the result of this evaluation
f ofx is the evaluation of the encrypted
function f uh on the input X and the
result is this Cipher Tex C so if we can
check this proof that guarantees that
this is really a cipher text obtained
from the honest evaluation then we can
also use the secret key for the fully
homomorphic encryption scheme to decrypt
the cipher text
C and note that this functionality that
I described here in this box is all
circuits in nc1 this is uh based on the
fact that we have uh uh proofs for which
verification algorithm is in nc1 and
also we have fully homomorphic
encryption schemes for which the
decryption circuit is also in
nc1 so now that
yeah uh output s
functionality so take as inut right we
but we need to to obtain F ofx right and
F ofx is only encrypted we have only F
ofx
encrypted yeah we have everything
encrypted so what we will do is we will
Opus skate this functionality right we
we we are trying to build an obfuscation
for the function f so we have to have F
encrypted we we are trying to hide
what's the
function so what we'll do is since we
already assume that we have obfuscation
for n C1 we will upate this shallow
circuit so this conditional decryption
would verify that whatever Cipher text
we we have feeded him uh it's really the
evaluation of the our opos cated
function on some some input and if this
verification holds then we can use the
secret key for the FH to uh decrypt the
final output so in this case our Opus
skater for any circuit would consist
of the FH encrypted function f together
with the obfuscation of this uh small
conditional decryption uh
circuit yeah where does SK come how do
you get SK to
the is that baked into the description
of the circuit so the SK is embedded in
here right this circuit will have SK
hard wired yeah so when you write you're
constructing the your obfuscation
algorithm will be the one that generates
the parameters for the FH you encrypt
the function that you'll be uh Opus
skating and then you generate the
obfuscation so we are assuming that we
have nc1 Opus skat right we are just
using it to uh to upate this uh function
here which consists of the proof
verification and then the FH
decryption so I have told you anything
about the proof yet right I I I I will
proceed with explaining what happens
with the proof so B was tching on the
correct question is that you can prove
this uh this uh construction secure only
if you assume virtual blackbox
obfuscation so that's why we have to
modify this construction so instead of
having uh one set of FH encryptions
we'll introduce a second uh parallel uh
FH encryption scheme so we will encrypt
twice our upated function under two
different FH encryption Keys we can
similarly obtain the evaluation the
encrypted uh the result of the
evaluation encrypted under the two
different Keys we can keep the
transcripts exactly in the same way we
can Define the conditional
decryption Ste in nc1 which is good and
we can obfuscate this part so now our
obfuscator for the whole P will consist
of the two uh encrypted uh functions F
under the two different keys and the
obfuscation of the condition of
decryption so now this construction is
good enough to prove from
indistinguishability ofation for
nc1 and here is an outline of the the
proof idea how we will show this so in
the proof we have to show in
distinguishability ofation we have to
show that this construction is a good in
distinguishability of Fator and as a
remind this means that we have to show
that the indistinguishability of vcation
of C1 of c0 and C1 when they evaluate
exactly the same function are
indistinguishable so we have to show
that this set of two uh cyer text and a
conditional decryption of vcation of the
conditional decryption is uh different
from these two where the difference is
really uh okay so let's go through the
steps so I will show you a number of
steps transformation that we will start
from this distribution and we will end
up in this distribution and I will show
you at each step why two consecutive
steps are
indistinguishable so what is the first
step well in the first step we will
change the second encryption instead of
encrypting the circuit c0 it will
encrypt the circuit
C1 and why do we claim that these two
are indistinguishable well we'll claim
that these two are indistinguishable
because of the uh semantic security of
the uh fully morphic encryption we just
have two different encryption uh
encryptions of two different uh plain
texts and also by virtue of the fact
that we haven't used anywhere the secret
decryption key uh for this second FH
what we are using here is the decryption
key uh for the red FH
parameters The Next Step will be
changing the obfuscation where instead
of embedding uh SK Z
will be embedding
sk1 and why these two hybrids will be
indistinguishable will come from the
property of the uh indistinguishability
of fation of nc1 because these two
circuits will still evaluate exactly to
the same on any input together with the
property that we have a perfectly sound
non-interactive witness in
distinguishable proofs which basically
means that uh nobody no adversary
uh can uh generate
uh can generate uh uh cheating proof
that would allow you to to decrypt if
you're not feeding exactly the same uh
encryption if you're not if if you
haven't evaluated the red Cipher Tex and
the uh yellow Cipher Tex on two
different uh on two different
messages so this indistinguishability of
these two steps follows from the
ofation the indistinguishability ofation
property for nc1 together with this uh
statistical soundness properties of our
proofs yeah why are those two circuits
evaluating
same one of them has SK Z sk1 so the so
this means that one of them is
decrypting the output here and one of
them is decrypting the output here we
know that these two circuits evaluate to
the same right this is the this is our
starting definition is that C 0 and C1
evaluate to the same on any input so you
just have to make sure that when you you
you produced a correct proof that says
that the yellow and the red were
evaluated exactly on the same input so
if we have guaranteed that they're
evaluated on the same input then you are
guaranteed that their outputs will be
the
same yeah need something like correct
andion uh
yeah yeah I mean you assume that the
decryption
always
yeah so
I where where do you use this you use
here the you use it by the fact that uh
you cannot provide inputs for the Opus
cations that evaluated the two Cipher
Tex on two different inputs right as as
part of the proof you you're checking
that the two Cipher texts that you're
giving into the obfuscation are
evaluation of the two encryptions of the
same function on the same
input because if you were able to feeded
two evaluations on two different inputs
then you will be able to I mean in in
one case you'll be decrypting the first
one in the other case you'll be
decrypting the second one and since if
you manage to cheat and provide two
different inputs then he will able to
evaluate so you have to guarantee that
he is not able to produce a cheating
that there doesn't exist a cheating
proof for this system and we I mean in
our paper we uh construct such a uh
proof system
will not
notation so I mean the the verification
algorithm is
ination the proof is
inine so the next step is uh just just
switching the first Cipher text the
security here is again from the semantic
security of FH and then the last step of
switching the keys back from sk1 to
sk0 uh again follows uh in the same way
as the previous
step so this is the outline of the uh of
the construction from nc1 to p uh now I
will proceed with the next uh clean
construction which is uh uh the
functional encryption construction
starting from Opus for all
circuits so let me Define what
functional encryption is uh so a
functional encryption consists of an
algorithm uh that produces uh the
parameters for the scheme which is a
public encryption key and then a master
secret key then we have an encryption
algorithm which takes a message and
encrypts that message under the public
key we also have a key generation
algorithm which takes the the master
secret key and the particular function
which will be associated with the
resulting decryption key so it it
produces a decryption key associated
with f and when we want to decrypt a
particular Cipher text that encrypts a
message M with a decryption key that's
associated with function f then the
output of this decryption is the
evaluation of f on the encrypted message
M so this is the formal definition of
functional encryption so let's see now
how uh we construct functional
encryption uh if we have obfuscation for
any
circuit so the setup uh for our
functional encryption uh scheme will
consist of generating uh two pairs of uh
parameters for semantically Secure
Public encryption uh
scheme then if we want to encrypt a
message M what we will do is we we will
encrypt the message under the two uh
public keys for the uh public encryption
scheme and then we will also produce a
proof that these two uh Cipher text
encrypt the same
message so our Cipher text will be two
Cipher Tex and uh a
proof
then if we want to generate a decryption
key for a function f what we will do is
we will will generate an obfuscation for
a
function that takes uh a function
encryption Cipher text which is two
regular Cipher text and the proof it
checks the proof which guarantees that
the two Cipher text encrypt the same
message and if this verification holds
then what we will do is we will decrypt
the first Cipher text which is under the
sk0 uh
key and then we will take this decrypted
value and we will evaluate on it the
function f and this will be the output
if this verification did hold then uh
the the decryption will
fail I mean this verification wouldn't
hold only if you don't have a correctly
constructed uh Cipher
text and then the decryption is easy we
just interpret uh the decryption key as
an off fiscated program and we evaluate
it on the uh on the particular Cipher
text so this is this is the whole uh
construction for the uh functional
encryption it's uh very uh similar to
the yeah so you're not actually
US1 or C1 anywhere yeah we will use it
in the proof we will need it only for
the proof which which appears on the
next
slide so uh why did we need really these
two parallel encryption schemes I mean
you can uh might be reminded of the
proof for CCA security from nor Yung
where they have this parallel um two
public uh key encryption
schemes
so what is uh I I never mentioned to you
what is the definition of security of
functional encryption so there are
different Notions of security for
functional encryption their simulation
definition which we know is impossible
and uh that's why we will prove security
for another uh uh security definition
which is IND distinguishability security
which roughly says that uh the
encryptions of two messages are
indistinguishable if you are given
decryption keys for function that
evaluates to the same value on the two
messages that's that's the intuition for
the uh security definition uh for
indistinguishability
so what does this mean is so we have an
encryption of the first message and then
we have a uh a decryption for a function
for a for a particular function
that that that um obay this property and
then we'll have the encryption of the
second message with the decryption key
of the same function so I need to show
you how to transition from this
distribution to this distribution and
claim that these steps are all
computational indistinguishability
so first step that we will do is we will
change uh the
encryption uh the the proof in this
encryption with the simulated
proof so for this we need uh we need to
have statistical simulation s
n which we know how to do The Next Step
will be once we have theim simulated
proof we can afford to change the
encryption in the second cipher text
from m0 to M1 because we already have
the simulated proof and the whole point
of the proof was to guarantee that these
two things are in the
same these two steps are uh
indistinguishable just from the semantic
security of the public key
encryption
then uh what we will do is we will start
actually using using the second uh en
the second uh encryption scheme
parameters so we will change the
decryption key instead of using uh the
decryption key for the red scheme to use
the decryption key for the blue scheme
which means that in the decryption step
you will decrypt the second cipher text
instead of the first one so here you are
decrypting c0 and then evaluating the
function here will be be decrypting C1
and then evaluate the function
f uh why are these two steps
indistinguishable well because we we
have a guarantee that F of m0 is equal
to F of M1 so these two obfuscations are
obfuscations of the fun of functions
that are really uh evaluating exactly
the same functionality they have the
same output on any
input right the the only reason is that
this is a simulated proof for the
challenge message and any adversary no
adversary can generate a simulated proof
so an adversary would be able to to uh
produce only valid encryptions that
encrypt the same two messages in the two
slots so these two decryption Keys
obviously will uh will evaluate to the
same and on this challenge message we
have the property that F of m0 is equal
to F of M1 so this follows that these
two steps are
indistinguishable and we basically
continue in the same way switching the
the first message back to M1 and then
switching the decryption key from using
sk1 to using
sk0 so this is basically the outline of
the proof for the
construction so now that we have gone
through all the nice constructions with
uh uh relatively clear proofs we will go
to the uh our obfuscation construction
for circuits in
nc1 so let's start uh with all the
ingredients that I will be using for for
this uh construction and then I will
tell you step by step how we'll put them
together into our
construction so we we will be using uh
representation of circuits in nc1 using
uh branching programs which were
introduced by barington we will also use
uh Kilian's technique for randomizing
branching programs we will also use
multi-linear maps for which we have two
construction of uh gar Gentry cevi and
then coron uh Le Point and
tii so we will put all these things
together and then I will describe
several uh different uh further
modification that are aimed to deal with
different uh issues that this original
construction will have they will come as
defenses to particular attacks that uh
we we saw in the the the original
construction and then at the end I will
state for you a complicated assumption
and give you some some uh point you to
some evidence that maybe it's it's a
good
assumption so what is uh uh Branch water
branching programs or oblivious
branching programs they were introduced
it's a computation of model which was
introduced by barington in '
86 so how do you describe a computation
with a branching program so uh if you
have a branching a branching program of
length M that takes input of length n
Bits consists of M pairs of matrices
which should be this should be 5x5
matrices so all these matrices are 5x5
matrices and then in addition to that
you have a function that tell tells you
uh that Maps uh any position in the
branching program to a bit in the input
so you have these tups for each position
tups of matrices for each position of
the branching program and then you have
a function that tells you for each
position in the branching program which
input you have to look at why would you
be looking at inputs well for the
evaluation the evaluation of a branching
program for a function
f cons consists is basically the
multiplication of all M of one Matrix in
each position where you choose which
Matrix to take depending on the input
bit in the position given by this
map so for each position in the
branching program you look at this
function
and if the input bit was one you use the
Matrix for uh a A1 and if this input bit
was Zero then you use the other Matrix
really I think the best thing is to look
at an example to understand how
branching programs work so imagine that
you have a branching program of length
nine so this means that you have nine
cupos of
matrices and if this branching program
has input of length four
bits and then the
map that Maps branching program
positions to input bit says that the
position Three 6 and 9 are determined by
the first bit in the input so if this
first bit is zero then for the
evaluation we have to use the matrices
that correspond to input Bit Zero then
similarly we can look at the subset of
position in the branching program
determined by the second bit in the
input so if that in input is one then we
take the other uh
matrices and we do the same thing with
the uh the rest of the input bits three
and four and for the evaluation of the
branching program we just select the
corresponding matrices and we multiply
them all together once we have
multiplied these matrices we check
whether the product is the identity
Matrix and if the product is the
identity Matrix this means that the
output of the evaluation is one and
otherwise the output of the evaluation
is zero this is how branching programs
work and this is how the computation in
a branching program is
described barrington's theorem says that
uh every function that's computable by a
depth D
circuit has a branching program
representation that is of length uh 4 to
the
D and what does this mean is that every
circuit that's in
nc1 which means that it's uh of depth
log all of log n uh has a branching
program of polinomial l so that's why
our construction would really be for for
work for functions in
nc1 so we have defined what a branching
program is let's try uh to see what uh
randomiz branching program is this was
an approach that was introduced by
Killian uh and in his paper we were he
was uh using randomized branching
programs for two-party
computation so we will use them in
different context
so if we started with a branching
program that was of length M and takes
input SI input of size n then we obtain
a randomized branching program by
sampling uh M random matrices random
invertible matrices also of size 5x5
it's missing here and we compute new
matrices which are the product of the
original matrices in the branching progr
Multiplied on both sides with two of the
random Matrix this is one the the Matrix
in position IUS one and then this is the
inverse of the following randomizing
Matrix at position I so basically you
insert all these M random matrices in
between your other matrices what this if
this enforce is really that the only way
to evaluate a branching program is in
the correct order you cannot mix
matrices and take up Matrix at position
10 and then put it in position two
instead of
that you keep the mapping exactly the
same the mapping between yeah when
duplication associative can you not
compute backwards and c and be parallel
and I mean you can compute different
different different the order of
multiplication but but but you can
certainly multiply all the all the odds
odd and even pairs together and then
yeah but you you will not you will break
the property of the uh branching program
that still comput it in par Yeah so
basically the randomized branching
program now consists of these new
randomized matrices and the original map
between uh positions in the branching
program and
input and this randomized branching
program provides a single input privacy
which means that if you look at the
matrices that correspond to a single
input for the evaluation these matrices
don't reveal anything more than the
output of the computation the only
meaningful thing you can obtain from
them is if you multiply them in order
and then compare them against identity
and this is basically the idea of uh
killington's to party computation
protocol and what what we want to do
here is we want to use this randomized
branching programs to do obfuscation we
want to somehow embed them in a that
says that when we give them out really
this is an ofation from the program the
only thing we can do is like is multiply
in the correct order and evaluate a
function we're still far from that and
uh so how would we want to use uh uh
this randomized branching program well
we want to uh compute a randomized
branching program uh for a universal
function and then provide for the
positions that are determined by the uh
opos skated function we will provide
only one of the randomized uh matrices
from the branching program and for all
positions that are determined from the
actual input on which we'll be
evaluating F then we will provide both
matrices uh we will evaluate the
obfuscation just in the same way we were
evaluating a a randomized branching
program of course this is uh uh not
sufficient construction because once we
give uh more than one input for a
branching program then more than one uh
Matrix for a position for the input then
the Privacy uh for the inputs is
lost so how are we going to fix this
problem well we would encode this
randomized matrices using multi-linear
Maps so that's how we will be hiding the
uh the matrices so let me Define what a
multi-linear map is it's is basically a
cryptographic uh primitive that allows
you to do both uh uh addition and
multiplication uh on encoded values so
you have you start with a several groups
and then you have a map that allows you
to compute uh operation on encodings of
two values that results into an encoding
uh of the product of this value and the
difference from a multilinear map and
fully homomorphic encryption is that you
have an additional property that you can
in this idealized definition of the
multilinear map you will be able to do
comparisons equality
comparisons in reality we don't have a
construction for this idealized
definition of a multilinear map what we
uh what we have is actually
approximation of a multi-linear map
where the encoding algorithm is uh
random IED algorithm it's not a
deterministic algorithm so we don't just
take uh G to the a for the for the
encoding but then we have a function
that's called zero test which basically
allows you to test whether a particular
encoding is an encoding of zero which
helps you do the the equality test the
hardness assumption for multi-linear
maps are analoges to the discrete log
and the multi-linear uh
ddh so we have two known constructions
for approxim multilinear maps and we
will be using
those so now that we have the definition
of this multi-linear Maps what we will
do is we will take the matrices from the
randomized branching program and we will
encode each entry in The Matrix using a
multi-linear map so this notation is a
bit abusing notation uh this basically
means that each entry in this randomized
uh uh Matrix is encoded using a
multi-linear map the properties of the
multi-linear maps just tell us that we
can perform the evaluation of the
randomized branching program underneath
the multi-linear map we can do the whole
um the whole multiplication of the
matrices and then at the end we can also
do the comparison of the result against
the identity Matrix again using the zero
test uh uh function from the
multi-linear
map so is this good enough for hiding
the the the matrices speed
I mean it looks pretty good but
uh there here is an attack that we can
still do even if we have done all this
encoding with the multi-linear maps so
imagine that uh we have a a randomized
branching program and we will be
evaluating this randomized branching
program on two different inputs x and x
Prime so the prescrib prescribed way in
which we can evaluate this is uh select
the corresponding uh matrices and then
multiply all of
them however what we can still do is we
can take subset of the positions like
consecutive positions still consecutive
positions but only subset of them and we
can do the correct computation and we
can compare these two values we still
have the power to compare these values
because the randomized matrices are
still
aligned and we have the zero test
property from the multi linear map and
what this attack roughly maps to is uh
uh learning whether the intermediate
values in the evaluations of these two
uh functions are equal this is a rough
mapping of what this attack allows you
to
learn another type of attack that still
not prevented is uh uh what is called a
mixed input uh attack so in a randomized
branching program we had this mapping
that tells you which positions in the
branching program are determined by a
particular input so in general in the
honest evaluation you what you should be
doing is you should be taking uh
matrices that correspond to the same bit
when you are evaluating a branching
program however so far we haven't done
anything that prevents an evaluator to
take an inconsistent set of uh matrices
for that position so he can take one
here and then zero and zero here so this
is what we we will call inconsistent
Matrix selection you can still do the
evaluation and test for the result
because all the randomizing matrices did
is to enforce you to take one Matrix in
each position but they didn't enforce
anything about consistency here so what
this attack roughly allows you to learn
is uh uh what happens with the
evaluation if you fix some internal wire
to a particular position Z to to
particular Bit Zero or
one so how what is the fix for these two
type of attacks that are still remaining
it's a technique that we call
multiplicative
bundling so what we will do is we will
compute constants for all positions in
the in the uh branching program that are
determined by the same input bit we will
compute uh constants and we will
multiply them into the B
matrices and this constants will be with
the proper that if you have taken the
matrices consistent matrices then this
constants will cancel out they will have
product one so if the these are the
matrices for Bit Zero or bit one they
will be canceling out however if you try
to multiply inconsistent matrices as in
the previous attack then this the
product of these constants will be
something unknown different from one and
this would eventually prevent you from
being you able to do the zero test in
the final outut out put so you would you
wouldn't be able to get any meaningful
information uh when you evaluate the
branching program with this inconsistent
set of matrices and then try to do the
zero test at the
end in fact what we do in our actual
construction is we do two we have two
parallel branching programs the real one
and then the dummy a dummy branching
program the dummy branching program
doesn't do any actual
computation the only Matrix that we are
embedding here is the identity
Matrix however the constants that we are
using in this real evaluation branching
program and in the dummy uh evaluation
program are chosen in such a way that
they enforce the consistency use of
matrices uh in positions that are
determined by the the same bit so we
make sure that the product of all the
alpha constants in positions determined
by the same input bit J is equal to the
product of of all the beta constants in
the positions determined by the same bit
J so now the
evaluation is evaluate the real
computation in the real branching
program evaluate the dummy branching
program then uh subtract those to cancel
out uh to cancel out the influence of
the randomizing constants and then apply
the zero test so basically this
multiplicative uh bundling insured uh uh
this
property unfortunately this still leave
some uh type of attacks in what you can
start what you can still try to do is uh
try to check whether you have somewhere
matrices inside the computation that
differ by a multiplicative constant just
by doing the multilinear map of entries
in the corresponding positions this same
thing allows you to compute an encoding
of the determinant of a matrix or try to
determine the uh rank of a matrix all of
this uh attacks on these pieces in the
constructions we don't know how to
leverage them into an actual attack of
the obfuscation there is no obvious way
how to leverage them however these are
not things that you would like to to be
able to do so even though we don't know
how to leverage into attack we try to
prevent all this kind of additional
computations that you can do with uh the
pieces in the
ofation and the counter measures that we
introduced to to uh stop these attacks
are the following what we will do is we
will embed the matrices from the
randomized branching program in a much
higher Dimension matrices so uh what
will be the dimension of these matrices
will be such that you if you try to do
things inside if you try to to do to
compute a matrix rank we want to
guarantee that you go beyond the uh
level for the multi-linear map and the
level of the multi-linear map tells you
how far you can apply the zero test and
learn useful things so basically this
this uh extension with the uh higher
Dimension matrices will prevent the
attacks that I listed in the previous
slide so now what we will do is we will
embed the matrices from the branching
program together with this randomizing
the multiplicative bundling constants in
the lower right corner then we will
Generate random values in the for the
rest of the diagonal and then we will
apply the randomization for the
randomized branching programs on top of
this uh newly expanded Dimension
matrices so this of course introduces
some issues in the correctness of the
evaluation of the branching program
because you still have the property that
your the multiplication in the lower
right diagonal will be the computation
of the branching program however all the
top diagonal entries that we introduced
to be random values they have no
relation in the two in the real
evaluation branching program and in the
dummy evaluation branching program so to
to manage this and get back the
correctness of the
evaluation uh we introduce what we call
uh bookend vectors this bookend vectors
will make sure that they would cancel
all the random values in the uh in the
diagonals in the top of the diagonals
and also we will make sure that the non-
cancelling part that will go in the
lower right corner or which is the part
of the randomized branching program they
will have the same dot product uh in the
real computation branching program and
in the D computation branching program
so and we will also apply the
randomization matrices we will like tie
everything together with the
randomization matrices by multiplying
this bookend vectors with the first
randomization uh Matrix from the order
and then we will multiply the last
randomization Matrix with the end uh
with the right bookend Vector so the
evaluation now will be not only the
multiplication of the matrices from the
original branching programs but also at
the end we will uh multiply with the two
bookend vectors which the bottom line of
this this computation will be that you
will cancel out all the random values on
the upper uh diagonal so you will be
canceling once you multiply with these
two vectors they will have zeros in
these positions so you will cancel the
effect of the entries in these diagonals
and you will be left only with the
result of the of the branching programs
which you can compare for
equality so if you didn't follow this
last part I will tell you that there is
a different way to enforce the same uh
the same property that is kind of much
cleaner and some Works after us
introduced it so just to recap what is
the construction for the obfuscation of
MC1 we start with a branching
program then we introduced the
multiplicative bundling that forces you
to use consistent matrices for each
input bit then we embed these matrices
in these higher Dimension matrices to
prevent all
these attacks that we don't know really
how to leverage to area one then we
randomize the matrices using the
randomization technique from
kium we compute our bookand vectors
which bring us back the uh correctness
for the computation that was destroyed
by the higher
Dimension as I mentioned there is is an
alternative approach where you start
using asymmetric multi-linear maps that
basically force you to use to do only
the correct uh uh computation and they
rely on some other uh uh assumptions but
I don't think they they introduce any
more uh assumptions that we already have
uh it's a much cleaner solution I I
would say so at the end once we have
obtained all this randomized uh matrices
we uh encod them with a multilinear map
that's uh has high enough level to allow
the uh evaluation of the M of the
computation for the branching program
but nothing
more and then once you have this
obfuscation uh the evaluation of the
obfuscation function is uh just
computation on the two branching
programs the real the real computation
and the dummy one and then compare the
results
so what is the security of this
construction so basically the assumption
that we have is that once you have this
transformation if you apply this
transformation on functions that on two
circuits that are implementing the same
function these two distributions of this
randomized encoded matrices are
indistinguishable basically the
Assumption say that once you're given
this uh uh obfuscation that consists of
this matrices the only way that you can
get useful information is to M multiply
them in the correct order and uh by the
virtue of the fact that these two
circuits evaluate to the same value
you'll be guaranteed that you will be
getting the same values in both
cases the evidence that this might be a
good uh a good assumption is that we
show that uh in our paper we show proof
of security of this assumption in a what
we call generic multilinear M matrix
model then a following work after us the
two following Works after us actually
showed that uh the security of this
assumption in the generic multi-linear
map model and also some even more recent
work shows that uh this is uh secure
even if you assume some uh some
different uh multilinear maps with a
different security property that satisfy
semantic security if you have a model in
your map that satisfy a property that
they call semantic security you can also
show the the security of this
assumption so these are all evidence
that maybe this assumption is uh is a
good assumption obviously this leaves as
the first big open problem uh from now
on is coming up with better
assumptions uh another things that are
interesting to look at are actually
coming up with stronger Notions of
obfuscation because in
distinguishability of fation is not
really good for everything it doesn't
really capture the initial intuition of
what we want to obtain from
obfuscation and possibly our current
construction act satisfies a much
stronger oce than indistinguishability
of fation there is a proof that in the
generic multilinear map model it's a
virtual blackbox obfuscation so we have
this this proof and we I mean we know
that imposs impossibility for virtual
black box but if we assume the generic
multilinear map model we can show that
our construction is satisfies this
property obviously the efficiency of the
construction is nowhere near to anything
practical another interesting question
is coming up with new uh more new
applications of of ofation we already
have seen a whole uh series of followup
work I'm sure that there are more in
store so with this I would like to thank
you and I would take any
questions
yes I saw paper on print at one point
saying that if you can do IND
distinguishing indistinguishability
optimation then knowledge extraction
assumptions are
invalid results comply that or
uh no I mean so I think there is such a
result but I mean this result doesn't
imply that I guess I mean it's a result
in general about the relation but I'm
not sure whether it was in
distinguishability ofation or uh uh some
of the stronger Notions of ofation you
might be right but yeah I mean the these
are relations that start to to give you
connections between things that we are
both guessing exist but uh maybe one of
them
doesn't